hello everybody at YouTube I'm Helen
Fisher I'm an anthropologist at work at
University and I studied the green and
what I guess I would like to go to
understand is that we've got to educate
little girls as well as little boys
because the female brain is very
different we evolved together millions
of years ago I see men and women in like
two feet they need each other to get
ahead and the female brain is on average
better connected giving them what I call
a web thinking they tend to think
holistically contextually synthetically
they think in webs of factors not
straight lines and as I've studied
people women tend to have a better
imagination because of this they tend to
be more mentally flexible they tend to
think long-term they tend to be quite
nurturing and they tend to be able to
live with ambiguity and i would say in
our modern world the most powerful if I
just sum up the modern world in one word
I would say it is contiguous and if we
begin to educate little girls we will
not only educate them that will educate
their children and their community and
help to change the world